son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
la Justicia de Guatemala suspendió la
candidatura presidencial del empresario
Carlos Pineda de Cara a las elecciones
del 25 de junio el ahora ex aspirante
que lideraba las encuestas acusó a la
corte de constitucionalidad de avalar el
fraude electoral Tenemos reporte
luego de que el presidente de México
para usar a las relaciones económicas y
diplomáticas con Perú su homóloga
peruana lo acusó de ignorante el nuevo
episodio se produce luego de que el
congreso de Perú declara la persona no
grata al mandatario mexicano
un nuevo ataque con misiles rusos sobre
territorio ucraniano dejó dos muertos en
la localidad de dinipro al tiempo que
una treintena de personas resultaron
heridas el bombardeo afectó un hospital
hecho que el presidente abuelo dimir
zelemski calificó como un nuevo crimen
de guerra ruso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Guatemala donde la corte
de constitucionalidad el máximo tribunal
del país suspendió la candidatura del
empresario Carlos Pineda quien lideraba
las encuestas de Cara a las elecciones
del 25 de junio se trata de una
ratificación de la decisión de una corte
menor que indicó que el partido
prosperidad ciudadana al que pertenece
Pineda incurrió en irregularidades en la
proclamación de sus aspirantes
previamente Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
corresponsal de France 24 nos explicó
cuáles fueron las irregularidades que
según la justicia llevan a la suspensión
de la candidatura de Pineda y Cuáles han
sido las principales reacciones
para entender la anulación de la
candidatura de Carlos Pineda el
candidato que lideraba las encuestas de
presidenciales aquí en Guatemala que se
había vuelto muy viral por cuenta de sus
redes en tiktok empresario de aeronaves
hay que remitirse al mes de noviembre de
2022 el mes del año pasado en el que su
partido prosperidad ciudadana debía
realizar una asamblea en la cual se
pudiera elegir a un comité ejecutivo de
este partido para también proclamar la
candidatura de este candidato sin
embargo ante el tribunal supremo
electoral esa asambleas estaba
realizando en Unas fechas extemporáneas
y no podía entonces Carlos Pineda lograr
esa candidatura pero la sala quinta de
lo contencioso administrativo falló a
favor de celebrar esta asamblea se pudo
realizar y luego vino una segunda
impugnación por parte de uno de los
miembros del interior del partido quien
dijo que se estaban imponiendo a la
fuerza los candidatos presidenciales
pero el tribunal supremo el no aceptó
esa denuncia por considerar la
extemporánea pero sí meses después
aceptó la denuncia de un otro partido el
partido cambio de la familia valdizón
una familia política empresarial muy
importante de Guatemala que otroramente
tuvo unas denuncias de lavado de dinero
por parte de los Estados Unidos y con
quien se tienen relaciones muy
cuestionadas con Carlos Pineda de manera
que se puede llegar a hablar de una
venganza electoral aquí en Guatemala
Aunque es un tema espinoso y hay que
mirar con mucha lupa la candidatura de
Carlos Pineda organismos internacionales
como human right watch denunciaron que
se trata de una Clara
instrumentalización del poder judicial
para garantizar un resultado electoral y
la Unión Europea dijo que ve con suma
preocupación que en Guatemala se están
expulsando arbitrariamente las
candidaturas presidenciales porque con
la de Pineda ya van tres
las tensiones entre México y Perú no se
detienen el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dijo este viernes que su
gobierno no quiere tener vínculos
comerciales ni económicos con Perú
mientras su homologada boluarte
permanezca en el poder por considerarla
una Usurpadora de la presidencia esto
ocurre luego de que ayer legisladores
peruanos declararan a López Obrador
persona en un grata en el país ampliamos
desde la capital Mexicana con nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonell
Mientras no haya normalidad democrática
en Perú no queremos relaciones
económicas ni comerciales con ellos así
lo dijo el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador en su conferencia de
prensa en Palacio Nacional esto Un día
después de que el pleno del Congreso
peruano lo declarara persona no grata al
cuestionarle si esto significaba una
ruptura acotó que Sencillamente todo
quedaba en pausa México es el tercer
socio comercial de Perú en Latinoamérica
después de chile y Brasil la nación
andina es la segunda receptora de
inversión extranjera directa mexicana en
la región empresas como femsa ica
América móvil grupo México son compañías
mexicanas con presencia en Perú
Por otra parte López Obrador reiteró que
no va a entregar la presidencia pro
tempore de la alianza del Pacífico al
gobierno de Dina boluarte por
considerarla una Usurpadora dijo en
cambio que está dispuesto a entregar la
presidencia de este mecanismo a Chile
para lo cual enviará una carta al
presidente Gabriel boric esta
declaratoria de persona no grata ha sido
interpretada por el partido Morena en el
senado de la República como un acto de
hostilidad hacia el gobierno de un país
hermano y una falta de respeto al pueblo
de México en contraste la oposición en
voz del partido Acción Nacional ha
considerado que los dislates ideológicos
del presidente mexicano que se ha metido
hasta la cocina en asuntos que no le
competen Nos tienen en una situación
como esta
en la madrugada de este viernes
autoridades migratorias en México
anunciaron el rescate de más de 100
migrantes en la frontera Sur viajaban en
un tracto camión que circulaba por el
estado de Chiapas y los agentes reportan
que fueron encontrados en condiciones
inhumanas este hallazgo es uno más de
las decenas de casos similares que
suceden en el país Azteca diariamente y
que han aumentado desde el fin del
título 42 en Estados Unidos el informe
es de Max Pérez Gallardo
el tráfico de personas en la frontera
sur de México se recrudece autoridades
del país Azteca encontraron vivos a 175
migrantes en la caja de un camión en el
estado de Chiapas al sur del territorio
mexicano con llantos y golpes al
vehículo los migrantes lograron llamar
la atención de los agentes migratorios
que cuando el vehículo fue detenido en
un retén lograron sacar al centenar de
personas que viajaban hacinados el
Instituto Nacional de Migración
autoridad encargada de vigilar los
flujos migratorios en el país publicó un
comunicado anunciando el rescate de los
migrantes con apoyo de la guardia
nacional y la policía estatal el camión
fue llevado a una zona segura donde
fueron contabilizadas 154 personas
originarias de Guatemala 13 de Ecuador
tres del Salvador tres de Honduras una
de República Dominicana y una de
Pakistán en una situación similar el
gobierno mexicano anunció el rescate de
más de 40 migrantes secuestrados en un
autobús al norte del país el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador alertó sobre
el aumento de secuestros a migrantes en
México hay bandas
que secuestran por eso también
el llamamiento
a los hermanos migrantes
que no se dejen
engañar manipular
por los traficantes las bandas de
contrabandistas de migrantes conocidos
popularmente Como coyotes son individuos
que operan en los pasos fronterizos de
México y que ofrecen llevar a los
migrantes por territorio Azteca
prometiendo el sueño estadounidense un
sueño que muchas veces se convierte en
pesadilla la comunidad afroamericana es
el grupo étnico con mayores tasas de
ataques fatales con armas de fuego por
parte de la policía en Estados Unidos
según datos recopilados de los últimos
seis años un niño de 11 años de
Mississippi estuvo cerca de sumarse a
esta estadística luego de que el oficial
que Atendió una llamada de emergencia en
su casa abrió Fuego contra el eumar esa
nos cuenta más
un disparo en el pecho
de 11 años llamó a la policía por
indicaciones de su madre ante la
presencia de un intruso el fin de semana
en su casa de indianola Mississippi una
comunidad de mayoría afroamericana 160
kilómetros de Jackson pero el niño
terminó recibiendo un disparo por parte
del oficial que fue atender los hechos
Él dijo salga con las manos arriba en
ese momento mi hijo salió salir con las
manos en alto y que te disparen no lo
entiendo
el niño estuvo cinco días hospitalizado
por la herida con un pulmón colapsado
laceraciones en el hígado y una costilla
fracturada El oficial gregkeipers fue
retirado de servicio activo mientras es
investigado pero aún goza de sueldo
familiares y vecinos de Adrián
protestaron frente al ayuntamiento de
indianola
[Música]
pedimos justicia un niño afroamericano
de 11 años estuvo a centímetros de
perder la vida no hizo nada malo hizo
todo bien
Qué amenaza suponía él es claramente un
bebé y tú eres un veterano oficial de
policía entrenado que parte de tu
entrenamiento te hace pensar que ese
bebé era una amenaza para ti
la familia ha pedido que se publique el
video de la cámara corporal del oficial
y que este se ha despedido y acusado de
asalto agravado Mississippi se ha visto
sacudido en días recientes por otro caso
de uso de fuerza letal por parte de la
policía en de un ciudadano afroamericano
tres ex oficiales tendrán que enfrentar
cargos criminales por la muerte en
custodia de un hombre de 41 años atacado
en repetidas ocasiones con una pistola
de aturdimiento durante un arresto nos
vamos a Turquía porque faltan menos de
48 horas para que comience la segunda
vuelta presidencial disputada entre el
presidente conservador reyeta y perdón y
el opositor que mal kilishrou este
viernes ambos candidatos me dieron sus
fuerzas en Estambul erdom se mostró
confiado en obtener la victoria gracias
a los resultados parlamentarios del 14
de mayo que lo favorecen por su parte
que listarolu basó su discurso en
criticar el manejo económico que Perdón
le ha dado al país así como su carácter
autoritario el informe es de Samuel
Salgado
quedan pocas horas para que concluya la
contienda electoral más agitada en los
últimos 20 años en Turquía el actual
presidente
aspira la reelección su intención de
volcar el sistema político Turco al
presidencialismo y su creciente
islamismo han deteriorado la situación
de Derechos Humanos en el país la
ventaja política que le dio el resultado
y las elecciones parlamentarias fue
usado por la mandatario para desafiar a
su oponente
señor
si es elegido presidente hay algo que
pueda ser después de no obtener el apoyo
del parlamento nuestra Alianza Popular
tiene 323 legisladores en el parlamento
cómo piensa apoyar los proyectos de ley
Perdón midió sus fuerzas en Estambul
frente a una multitud de Seguidores
el presidente también cuenta con el
apoyo de nanogan quien quedó de tercero
en la primera vuelta el 14 de mayo y
cuyos votos provienen de una base social
de derechas racionalista misma base
social que el segundo aspirante de la
presidencia que mal cristal oglu ha
tratado de persuadir con su discurso
antimigrante
este viernes en un mitin también desde
Estambul cristal oglu basó su Campaña en
la recuperación económica
la situación en la que se encuentra
nuestro país en este momento no es buena
Turquía necesita salir de esto
reemplazaremos Un gobierno autoritario a
través de medios democráticos
con una inflación que alcanzó el 85% el
año pasado el poder adquisitivo es un
tema decisivo en las urnas
en noticias de la guerra en Ucrania o
misil ruso impactó este viernes en un
centro hospitalario en la localidad de
ucraniana de nípro dejando dos muertos y
una treintena de heridos al menos tres
en estado crítico
las infraestructuras médicas ucranianas
de nuevo bajo las bombas rusas un misil
del kremlin impactó en una zona
Residencial en la ciudad de Nitro en el
centro del país sus habitantes siguen
conmocionados
lavando los platos Y entonces subimos
una fuerte explosión fui lanzada por el
impacto de la explosión hacia un lado
hacia la pared por suerte la distancia
era corta
los rescatistas se esfuerzan por Apagar
las llamas de esta clínica de Salud
Mental pero varios edificios al de años
también se vieron afectados por la onda
expansiva de la bomba
Esta es una zona Residencial detrás a
instalaciones parques infantiles un
estadio escuelas aquí ni siquiera hay
fábricas normales ni ninguna necesidad
de defensa es 100% una zona Residencial
este sería el décimo tercer ataque ruso
con drones bomba y misiles en lo que va
de mes el presidente boloñir selenski
acusó a Rusia de cometer un crimen
contra la humanidad
un misil Ruso balístico contra un
hospital y una clínica veterinaria
criaturas absolutamente enfermas
haremos todo lo posible todo lo
imposible para acelerar el suministro de
más sistemas de defensa antiaérea de
mayor calidad a Ucrania esto es
literalmente una cuestión diaria de
trabajo con los socios
Mientras tanto el conflicto se siente a
diario en las regiones rusas fronterizas
esta semana legionarios y voluntarios de
origen rusos contrarios al kremlin
reivindicaron ataques contra Belcorp así
llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Natalia Cabrera con toda la
información del continente americano en
aquí América feliz noche para todos